[Music]
this might seem like a vacation but for
entrepreneur and trinidad native marquis
farrell
[Music]
from the shore to the streets
farrell has a lock on his hometown
you want to try this coconut jelly sure
ah so refreshing and every taste it has
to offer one with sweet and pepper one
with no no sweet and pepper pepper yeah
i put sweet salt and pepper sauce on
everything
it really brings the flavor out
and now he's serving up one more a rum
that he says is a cut above called ten
to one people have thought about rum for
a long time as a very sort of like
narrowly defined spirit like spring
break only
sugary slushy cocktails that they had
that one time in cancun or whatever and
like the spirit is actually way more
versatile way more elevated than that
some say ferals perfectly suited as ceo
of an up-and-coming multi-faceted spirit
brand we're trying to kind of bring this
this perspective of not just rum but rum
culture caribbean culture bring it to a
global platform an mit cambridge and
harvard business school grad
he climbed the corporate ladder at
starbucks the youngest vice president in
the company's history he brings all of
that to a brand that he says goes beyond
so it's not just the rum it's not just
the rum you know i think um
look the rum is exceptional take it from
me take my word for it right i think
it's an opportunity to again shine a
light on a different side of our culture
and hopefully take it to a global stage
for the caribbean
that story dates back to colonial times
when enslaved africans were forced to
harvest sugarcane by hand and may have
developed a way to distill the excess
juice known as molasses into rum the
spirit became an unexpected hit often
used as currency that helped fuel and
extend the slave economy when people try
to understand how celebration has become
such a part of the fabric of our people
if you will i think understanding some
of those roots that genesis born out of
the plantation in the context of um born
out of cambodia and born out of struggle
in the context of carnival you actually
then begin to understand how it releases
underpinning of so many different facets
of our culture the africans want their
freedom
the kambulay ceremony originated in the
emancipation of slaves in trinidad in
1838
as seen in this reenactment
the burning of sugar cane was symbolic
of suffering and resistance
in 1881 the british government tried to
stamp out the annual celebration leading
to riots
carnival has its roots in that history
and is now known as one of the greatest
street parades in the world
and energy feral is trying to bottle
with ambassadors who take ten to one to
another level pop star sierra is now an
investor it was a pretty magical moment
you know i mean c is is is uh
c or sierra
c c sierra
now she's amazing she in so many ways is
emblematic of a lot of the elements of
caribbean culture i was mentioning that
i think we want to put on a global stage
somebody who is spontaneous and
optimists has range
elevated but doesn't have a overly
exclusive vibe to them you know they're
willing to welcome others in
also important elevating local
celebrities like artist jimmy october
[Music]
you can't help but move right you have
to do it who's carving out his own genre
new calypso
i mean i think of calypso i think of
harry belafonte
bringing
something called new calypso is paying
respect to what has passed on what is
already here but add another bit of new
youthful energy into it let's be super
clear there's this whole new generation
of creators i call them creators of
culture and you'll see them doing their
thing and music and you'll see them
doing their thing in fashion you'll see
them do anything in art and what i love
about this new generation hopefully i'm
a part of it is it like i think you are
you think i'm a part of it absolutely
what i love about this generation is
like
we
are doing it unapologetically so where
are you taking it taking inside 36
cornelio which is a really cool
a little fashion forward
designer and fit grad levi marcus is
part of it too he has a clothing line
collaboration with ten to one i think
the caribbean has a lot of global
influence but we don't get the credits
that we deserve
and ultimately i think
working with mark you know you guys
coming here giving us the opportunity to
put our culture out there is really
important
ten to one stands for many things the
federation of ten caribbean nations that
unified their economies from 1958 to
1962
and its initials even mimic that of
trinidad and tobago so it's a little a
little hidden shout out to the home
country
we're thinking we're thinking a shout
out that is making waves in america in
michelin-starred restaurants like 11
madison park and new hot spots like
french indonesian eatery weigh-in
it all keeps ferrell pretty busy
branding selling re-imagining
drawing inspiration from his family his
friends
and his fellow creatives
for him
ten to one is a way to show the world
that there's no place like his home i
would love to pretend to want to be
category redefining success is all about
like the value that that you claim i
think significance in a lot of ways
about what you are able to contribute
for me it's important that like as part
of what 10 to one does on this journey
is that it provides a little bit of a
platform provides a little bit of a
voice continues to elevate our view of
the the culture that i'm so proud to be
a part of right like if that doesn't
shift as a part of ten to one's
continued growth and success then it
feels like an incomplete story to me